how are these labels [__] artists
with the streams I don't know how
they're doing it but it feels like
they're doing it and how are they
tricking us because I see these people
that go crazy album goes number one but
then they can't fill up a show right so
the math is not math right right yeah I
mean that's what it is but explain it
where I mean so it's it's um it's one of
those things that like everyone in the
industry knows is going on which is
faking the Stream
it's a real thing so the label buys the
streams from Spotify so here's the deal
when you talk to these people cuz I've
talked to these people cuz I've been
like what's what is this how are y'all
doing this they never disclose the
mechanics of like how they actually fake
the streams there's like you know um
rumors of like streaming Farms or we're
delving out [__] computers in third
world countries and hacking the back end
to make it look like it's an IP from the
U whatever like all it's nutty [__] but
the reality is the labels are spending
money and you know Devil's Advocate
they're treating it like a marketing
expense cuz in a sense it like almost is
you're going to spend 100 Grand on
billboards you're going to spend 100
Grand on streams right streams is going
to put you in a playlist you're going to
spend real money to get fake streams
that equate to real money so that's why
they think it makes sense because it's
like okay the streams are fake but the
money's real so what do we care
especially not doing it with like upand
cominging artists who like you wouldn't
believe it you know they're doing it
with people like where it's okay if your
let's say your song has 500 million
streams right organically but let's say
with fake streams now you're at 900
million no one's going to sit there and
be like this is more like a 500 million
stream song they're just going to be
like this is a big song makes sense it
has 900 million honestly so smart yeah
they're not like they're not doing it to
the dude across the street and giving
him a billion streams they're doing it
to people who really can get half a
billion but let's just pump it to get
900 yeah now you're getting number one
now you get number one you could pay for
a number one oh yeah what what does the
number one
cost I mean that's crazy been think
about what is the number one song in
America cost look the the reality is
this you do have to have a real fan base
to a certain extent right you have to
have people who are really consuming the
music and your song has to actually be
moving around organically once it's that
then they'll push the button on it and
it just depend like it's a campaign it
could be like it's like a 12we campaign
and it might be 60 Grand 70 grand
whatever it is that's it and it's oh
yeah to have the number one song and
that 70 grand the ROI is crazy because
that 70 grand might bring you back 200
300 yeah and even just seeing the song
number one you're more likely to check
it out now how right because people are
sheap and it's just yeah yeah if you see
something sucessful labels are like all
CEOs at labels are obsessed with market
share like who has the market share Sony
has 25% market share means the amount of
streamed yeah like who songs at that
moment right total streams how many
percents yours right and there's like
bonuses that are associated with that's
their incentive structure if you're
number one you're going to get the
trickle down so they're going to try to
boost
right now you I maybe you can't quantify
it but you said you can't do it with any
song you could take it from number 10 to
number one or you got to be like three
and then I look Spotify even just put
out this statement that
said um anything over what was it 80% or
90% yeah yeah yeah anything over 90
they're going to call out so you could
be 89% fake streams that's what over
it's like that's that was spotify's way
of saying we know what's going on we're
okay with it we're profiting off it it
just can't of course because somebody
doing a billion streams on your platform
is a good look for your
cuz you're bragging about the amount of
streams on your platform think think
about where Apple music loses the
Spotify one they don't show the streams
two when it came out like last year that
there was only one song that has a
billion streams on there like it just
doesn't look as sexy as Spotify and I
feel like as a consumer oh nobody's
listening to Apple music Spotify must be
better I don't know [__] I'm just going
to go with the bigger one so the big
streams help the artist and the platform
oh yeah and the label so like everyone
wins that's why no one's going to say
anything think about it if you're
investing Spotify if your money is in
Spotify shares you want to know that
it's getting the most streams and it's
beating Apple by X am and the labels are
invested I remember when I was it's the
craziest [__] I remember when I was with
Colombia and
Colombia um you know there was a there
was a point in time where like they sold
their shares or Spotify whatever the
[__] but everyone on the label just
depending on how many streams you were
doing you got a check I got a crazy
check from Colombia selling their shares
of SP
Spotify huh why did you get that crazy
because I was doing a lot of streams on
Spotify you get your share of the stream
money right right so so this is crazy
Billy Corgan was on Rogan talking about
this did you see that episode where he
was like and again I don't know how
factual this is but this is what he said
he's like the
labels took Equity pieces in the
streaming platforms and then gave the
stream the streamer sweetheart deals on
the artist music so basically we're
going to charge you less yeah for the
artist music which means the artist gets
less but we are personally going to take
Equity positions in those companies
right so give me a little bit of Spotify
I'm going to give you this artist music
for a little but when your brand builds
because it needs us to build I get that
but you know who doesn't get that the
artist the artist which is crazy yeah
but and you know but it's like the
artist uses all of that for leverage to
go get sponsorships and it's all like
Fame driven yeah yeah it's all like the
streams might be fake but me being
perceived as a massive artist make money
on the so now now I'm getting this now
I'm getting that and I'm monetizing with
this brand or with this sponsorship
whatever it is so it's like it's all
just a [__] finesse and it's all a
scam and there's some artists that are
like I'm just going to live off of my
deal right they're like I don't even
care if I make enough money to pay back
right the company or the the label
whatever it is they're going to give me
my Advance that's what I make yeah right
and well and it's so funny when artists
are like I haven't seen a check since I
got signed it's like cuz you're not rec
make money what are you so confused
about it's like you didn't make the
money back artists don't know oh yeah I
think I I don't think any of the artists
know that their streams are being faked
wow no but that's and and here's the
thing here's the thing right that's
heartbreaking no but here's the thing
that's why first of all I encourage
every artist audit your label make sure
there's an audit Clause like I'm
auditing you know
who I was with and um a lot of money
being found yeah yeah because the
reality is like you don't know there's a
lot of things that are just hidden in
those statements and the marketing
expenses and the reason why like it's
the like if you're signed to a major
label right it's so easy to just deny
everything because there's a buffer
there's a label the label is the
middleman between the fake streams and
you so if it comes out that so and so is
faking their streams you could just play
done be like I had no idea the label
must have did it yeah I didn't know what
the label was spending their money on
and when I have a hit song that has a
billion streams I'm not going to go are
we short this is not me like speculating
right this is me talking to like top
five most streamed artists in the world
and them talking to CEOs and CEOs
admitting and me on the phone with like
managers of massive artists and on the
phone with the dude who fakes the
streams and them saying like what's
going on wow dude you know what I just
so this is not it's not like a not
sitting here like conspiratorial this is
like I really think people are fake and
like once you know it's really easy to
tell which songs are being fake who's
the most fake no I can't say come on
listen I'm not gonna we were talking on
brilliant idiots and Charlamagne said it
was it was a Drake song that came out
was a Drake and SZ song s yeah and he
was like it went number one one week
yeah and the next week it just fell off
right right right and he was like listen
those are the types of things where you
go are these songs being pumped up by
the label because I think DOA cat song
painted town red had been in that top
five for weeks right that you're not
going to keep faking streams for are for
real I'm not saying that she was doing
that you would fake streams for months
I'm just saying like this this is the
thing think of the perception you just
you're getting real like it has to be a
song but there's going to be diminishing
returns if you keep having to spend 100
grand every month no well it's not 100
grand every month uh because it's really
just a spending enough money to hack the
algorithm so 69ine was right is that
what you're trying to say what was he
saying depends on what he
said right about what
Fair no he said something about they
took his number one by buying streams
for some artists yeah I mean like the
reality is they're not going to do it
and it doesn't make sense to do it with
something that's not already a moving
train got it when it's already a moving
train the public won't know the
difference you know what I'm saying like
if it's a song that genuinely has half a
billion streams if we juice it and now
it has 900 million like I said you're
not going to sit there and be like N I
don't believe it has 900 because it's
massive organically yeah so D and what
was it certified lover boy when we were
all really fixated on who's going to be
number one whoever was number one
theoretically they could have just paid
and be like for sure for sure and almost
makes me sorry but but it's like the
labels are look it's a business they're
looking at it like we're protecting our
investment one and we're trying to uh
obtain as much of the market share as
possible and they also know this is just
like a psychology thing it's like fake
commotion ends up creating real
commotion you know what I'm saying like
if I'm just over here making a spectacle
and it's a fake spectacle the fake
spectacle attracts real eyes and now the
real eyes are over here like what is
that spectacle and now I have real
people tuned in off of fake commotion so
here's a question CU we we I we all see
academics as posts about who who sells
what in the first week or whatever I
think it was French Montana had like a
really bad first week is that French
Montana standing on his own honor being
like I refuse to play into this buy any
streams or do you think the label might
be like I'm assuming with a label would
be like you we're kind of done with you
and this is you're going to have an
embarrassingly low number cuz it's the
real number whereas everybody else
getting inflated but your [__] is going
to sit low I don't know what his
situation well I know like French is my
guy and I actually like helped him get
the deal that he has I think French is
great I think but it's like yeah either
you know sometimes maybe it's not just
so transparent where they're like hey do
you want to fake your streams or not you
know what I mean yeah or it's like it's
not a moving train so we're not going to
push the button on it because it's not a
moving train yet yeah if the if the
album came out with some heat then they
could put the put it like this put it
like this full transparency now I also
know and I've said this in interviews
before like this is the thing I'm like
worried about is like me pointing the
finger and calling [__] out M all that's
going to happen is people like no no no
you're faking your stream you know what
I'm saying you know so much right like
how do you know and you were on the
phone n you know what who even listens
to Russ you're faking your but now but
you got people coming out to shows I
think that's the difference real bodies
but I will say this for full
transparency like this like this is the
truth 315 is a song I have that I put
out I don't know two years ago three
years ago and right now it's doing I
don't know 500,000 streams a day on
Spotify there was a time where it was
doing 800 to 900,000 right and the
threshold to go to today's top hits is
like they want to see you getting like
1.1 right and that's like once you're in
today's top hits over with right so we
got on the phone because I was like
Milan I hit my manager I was like Milan
see what this guy like CU I've like low
key I'm like planning like a [__]
Vice documentary I'm like
exposing I'm like Milan hit this guy
like is the like
[Laughter]
process but it's like so so he talks to
him and he's like look you know you got
a fake voice this is the perfect song to
do it because it's crushing organically
nobody's going to know the difference
between 200,000 streams 315 organically
was the before Tik Tok and billboard did
the thing where there was a Billboard
Chart for Tik Tok songs 315 was the
number one song on Tik Tok in the world
you know what I mean organically so once
again if I was to boost that what is
anyone gonna say no I hear it everywhere
on Tik Tok so it kind of checks out
makes sense and we talked to the dude or
Milan talked to him and told us you know
it's like a 8 to 12 week campaign you
spend 3540 Grand and like that's it then
it's out of here and now guess what now
it goes from once again it goes from
800,000 organic streams a day to now
maybe it is doing that 1.2 million
threshold and now Spotify puts it in
today's
you see what I'm saying and now radio's
like wait this is a smash it's a
multiplier and so all a sudden that
extra 400,000 streams that are fake get
a whole bunch of real ears and real but
I just could not live with myself I did
it because the reason why like I'm going
be honest it's so tempting y right I've
even tweeted about it before where it's
like wait a second if everyone's on
steroids am I an idiot yeah yeah it's
the baseball [__] am I an idiot right
like am I being naive and almost
childish where it's like I'm sitting
here still trying to like play the game
the right way and everyone else is like
dog what are you doing like you know you
know we're all doing this right and so I
start you know I oscillate with like yes
and no every day but I just have faith
and I know that that house is going to
come crumbling down and I don't want to
be in it when it does because guess what
it'll do it won't just be oh Russ you
fake the streams on 3:15 it'll send the
whole catalog in the question right
especially because and I that would
[__] ruin me especially because
you're independent right if you're not
independent if you're already part of
the label system right even if you put
it all into question they wouldn't be
incentivized that terum down but to you
oh yeah there are people I'm sure that
are part of the industry that've heard
all the [__] that you said and then seen
your success without them and they're
like they're waiting for me to fake my
the second if I did it second I did it
it would be Russ is faking his and let
this be a lesson to all other
independent artist cuz guess what that
narrative is now the narrative would be
see you can't get real success
independent unless you fake your stram
you got to be with a major so like I
just feel I owe it not just to myself
but to the whole like Independent
Community to do it the real way and and
look if that means that I have a ceiling
here then so be it but at least this is
real yeah why are yall doing billions of
streams and the tickets don't matter PR
guys and if you use the promo code
Schultz they will match your initial
deposit up to $100 so you put up 100 you
get 100 for free why don't you gamble
with $100 free doar price.com now let's
get back to the show